on parle forcément du mariage Guay pour
ouvrir cette édition avec ces photos
parues dans la presse et qui font
beaucoup parler depuis hier alors
c'était lor pardon vous allez le voir de
la manifestation parisienne des
opposants projet derrière cette
banderole Gilbert Collard le député du
rassemblement bleu marine et à ses côtés
de nombreuses élu évelinois alain
GOURNAC sénateur UMP Christine Boutin
conseillère général et présidente du
parti chrétiendémocrate Jean-Frédéric
Poisson député de cette même formation
encore François deasier député divivers
droite maire de Versailles un peu plus
loin on retrouvver également Henri Gueno
député UMP UMP et Front national
scandant les mêmes slogans Jean-François
Copé est intervenu en précisant qu'il
n'accepterait aucune collusion avec
l'extrême droite il parle d'un simple
voisinage malheureux toujours concernant
les evelins ce rassemblement la veille
de cette grande manifestation à Paris
c'était à laavrière dans une ville très
encrée à gauche l'une des dernières
détenu par le Parti communiste français
collectif qui se dit à politique a tenu
à mobiliser les citoyens un reportage de
Julie Rocha Soarez
etod 2 3 VI les
enfants opération un manifestant un
ballon à La Verrière ce samedi une
vingtaine d'antiariage pour tous réunis
à l'appel du collectif La Verrière pour
la famille c'est pas un mouvementtique
est 6 ans c'est un mouvement qui
regroupe des verrierrois de tous âges
pour sensibiliser les verrierrois sur
les conséquences de la loi les
conséquences qui sont dramatiques pour
les enfants pour les familles avec le
risque de la PMA procréation
médicalement assisté et de la GPA les
mères porteuses on n'est pas vraiment
contre le mariage homosexuel mais ce qui
accompagne tout simplement cette loi la
PMA tout ça aujourd'hui en France par
exemple des lois sur les OGM on les a
recaler en disant on n pas assez le
recul dessus et là pour la PMA on nous
l'a fait passerette force nous sommes
Mobil is pour défendre effectivement le
la famille la famille et les droits de
de l'enfant d'avoir un père et une mère
reconnu qu'ils aient effectivement leur
racine connu reconnu et non pas
effectivement une constitution d'une
famille qui n'en serait plus une
voulez-vous du changement de
civilisation qu'on cherche à nous
imposer ce rassemblement d'une
demi-heure était le préambule de la
manifestation parisienne du lendemain
contre le mariage pour tous l'occasion
de répéter leur slogan la loi on n'en
veut pas on veut du boulot pas du
mariage au mot les antimariages pour
tous précise qu'ils ne lâcheront rien
pour reprendre leur terme et penseent
même à un recours constitutionnel si la
loi est votée solennellement mi à
l'Assemblée
nationale le lendemain ses opposants se
sont donc retrouvés à Paris si le nombre
total de manifestants fait toujours
débat de 45000 à 270000 personnes selon
les sources bien sûr Henry gu a été
clair le député de la 3è circonscription
des ivelines juge que le préfet de
police doit changer de métier sur BFM TV
il a estimé que les chiffres des
officiel était totalement mensonger et
ridicule une nouvelle fois il l'a
rappelé si on continue à mépriser Heins
si les manifestants ça va très mal se
terminé enfin cette dernière information
le mouvement de la manif pour tous
franchit également un pas de plus et se
projette vers les municipales de 2014 il
y aura des candidats portant cette
étiquette c'est une déclaration de
Christine Boutin la conseillère générale
des Yvelines ce lundi des candidats qui
se présenteront dans les villes dont les
élus n'ont pas joué le jeu selon des
propos de frigide bargeot l'autre chef
de fil des opposants